bonjour les p'tits potes alors déjà
merci car vous êtes désormais 8 millions
d'abonnés à ma chaîne youtube champagne
alors ça fait super longtemps que
j'attends de faire cette vidéo basse et
correspond pour moi après deux trois ans
de travail j'ai donc hyper content et
hyper fière de représenter le dvd de mon
spectacle et son calepin web et les
confitures va le faire à chaque fois 1
moi souvent les gens quand ils voient
dans la vraie vie et savent qu'ils m'ont
vu quelque part mais savent plus trop où
l'info ya un mec qui m'a fait et c'est
toi
internet c'est ça je suis internet et ça
s'emboîte russie alors vous avez été
quatre cent mille à venir me voir dans
plus de 300 dates en france mais aussi
en belgique en suisse au maroc et au
québec tabarnak c'est le même spectacle
que je loupé le début il n'a qu'un seul
c'est celui ci est maintenant ce
spectacle est là dessus j'en redemande
toujours
est ce que ton charente et vidéo et ce
ton fraîcheur maintenant c'est un
comédien
alors j'ai été mis en scène par un
monsieur qui s'appelle kader aoun je
suis hyper fier d'avoir travaillé avec
lui parce que tout ce qu'il a fait dans
sa carrière basse et mes références de
quand j'étais petit il a mis en scène et
de spectacle culte de jamel el akri le
jamel comedy club il a créé le burger
quiz il a créé h et plein d'autres trucs
pourris mais ça il m'a demandé de ne pas
en parler
bon c'est distribué par tf1 moi je
méconnais pas trop très honnêtement et
c'est quand même assez flatteur de me
dire que j'ai le même distributeur plus
gad elmaleh florence foresti et maya
l'abeille alors on a filmé le spectacle
à la cigale à paris alors pourquoi la
cigale simplement ce que c'est la
première grosse salle parisienne dans
laquelle je les jouais pour moi c'était
donc assez symbolique alors pour le
décor j'avais pas envie d'avoir un vieux
fond noir tout neutre je voulais avoir
ma petite touche à moi avoir un décor
qui me ressemble alors j'ai carrément
travailler avec une entreprise de
décoration on à dessiner des croquis
puis en 3d un appart inspiré du mien
avec dedans des objets qui m'ont
vraiment appartenu et puis une lumière
un peu intimiste pour donner
l'impression d'être dans mon univers
quand je suis sur scène moi j'ai pas un
mec issue la culture hip hop que j'ai
pas la street cred
jusque récemment je suis retrouvé
embarqué dans une soirée hip hop avec un
pote soirée cauchemardesque
déjà on arrive devant la boîte hip hop
le vigile attendez les gars vous êtes 2
s'est pas accompagnée par théo revenait
quatre filles peut-être que vous
rentrerez j'ai tremblé faire un ton mec
a comparé et on trouve quatre filles on
revient pas
c'est notre rêve
il n'a jamais violé des potes j'en fais
rentrer tu vois dans cette boîte juste
taper la honte de ma life tous les mecs
étaient ultra stylée hip hop tout sur
barack est sûre tatouer des petites
bagues aux doigts et le mec qui arrivait
à rester viril emportant deux boucles
d'oreilles c'est moi je mets deux
boucles d'oreilles on est d'accord je
met un pied dehors je me fais violer et
tous les mecs étaient hyper bien habillé
hip hop ils avaient des lotisseurs de la
nba qui vont jusqu'aux genoux - mais ça
on dirait une robe de chambre c'est sûr
oui tout le monde une couche et au
revoir
il s'arrêtait pas tape les frères entre
les frères bien bien frères soeurs et
frères
moi j'veux pas dire frères avec mon
visage moi si j'ai des frères on dirait
que sur une artère fait à benoît
fermés noir j'ai pris un peu l'église
je pensais au mois souvent après le
spectacle les gens me font des petits
commentaires
alors c'est toujours intéressant à
entendre et plutôt agréable sauf quand
c'est ce que j'appelle un faux
compliment véridique
récemment une fille a cru me faire
plaisir en disant quand j'ai su que
j'allais venir te voir en spectacle je
me suis dit ok ce soir je pose mon
cerveau sur le côté et je profite
ok bah merci vu que tu me fait cette
remarque hyper agréable
je vais demander ton cerveau depuis
tulle à récupérer ou pas façon que ce
soit vraiment spectacle pour mes vidéos
je vous jure dans la vie j'ai toujours
le droit à des gens qui font défaut
complément comme ça j'en parle
d'ailleurs un peu dans mon spectacle
mois un fois que le restaurant le savoir
il m'a un peu reconnus par rapport aux
vidéos il est venu me voir sauf qu'il
m'a dit un truc j'ai pas trop kiffé
c'est la revue l'a fait excusez moi j'ai
un peu honte de l'avouer j'ai un peu
honte mais j'aimais ce que vous faites
attend 5 en volume en insultant en plus
de mon spectacle dans ce dvd vous
trouverez un petit documentaire des
caméras l'ont suivi pendant deux ans
dans cette petite salle le stand up à
paris qui s'appelle le paname où je
venais tous les soirs 7 jours sur 7 pour
écrire mon spectacle et m'entraîner sur
scène et ça je sais d'expérience le mec
ne pas excuser en bourse vous trouverez
aussi dans un bonus
je me suis amusé à répondre directement
sur scène aux questions du public moi je
voulais savoir si tu regardes et tu es
vidéos jeux
jamais vu
c'est pas mon style
je suis pas abonnés à ce genre de truc
moi c'est squeeze squeeze à mort vous
pourrez voir dans ce dvd un blog
spécialement dédié à ma tournée en
suisse
c'est à dire ma tournée suissesses ouais
on dit suissesses sont constants cadets
la puissance du pecq
qu'ils cherchent
témoin d'appareils photos de façade
enfin dans ce dvd il ya un petit calepin
a dessiné par un très mauvais
dessinateur qui ai moi même
par exemple à ses ancêtres mois avec des
yeux de d'extraterrestres des croquis
des blagounettes des souvenirs de
tournée une tablature pour apprendre à
jouer la chanson sur scène web parce
qu'à une chanson des petits jeux d'une
difficulté extrême des quiz et plein de
dessins très moche mais rigolo alors
vous trouvez mon dvd dans tous les
magasins hyper culturel 1 comme
carrefour leclerc auchan à part
peut-être chez castorama et je crois que
dedans il ya un petit code de réduction
pour venir me voir en décembre au zénith
je peux la voir
et bien sûr il est dispo aussi en blu
ray et en digital sur toutes les
plateformes dont la chaîne youtube
alors pour une fois je fais un petit peu
sérieux désolé mais s'il vous plaît ne
piratez pas mon spectacle pur occupants
et enfin pour répondre à tous ces
messages twitter qui me demandait quand
est ce que le dvd sort je vous donne la
réponse
il sort maintenant